[Música]
ella en verdad
estas son las recetas estaban todos los
días por mi cabeza
todos
yo soy en este área
aprender
honestamente el recibimiento de esa
ciudad de panamá
conocida de edad
me dijeron que era mucho
media después de cuestionarme todos los
días sobre mi decisión
mediante de 4 y orar
por fin encontré un lugar
de moda
conocí a una mujer que me dio la
oportunidad de crecer y aprender de
trabajar
durante tres años
y me enseñó una nueva definición de
mujer
tomar decisiones
en mi casa como cualquier otra
desafortunadamente no tengo muchos
recuerdos
no recuerdo caminando
no recuerdo el mensaje del departamento
no veo la hora de la mañana
porque la verdad
el día
las que con mi hermana
sobre las grandes que tenían para el
siguiente años
sobre la zona
sobre lo tengo entonces el fin de semana
[Música]
entonces
definitivamente
en esta lista
d
a verdes
nos conocíamos
sabemos lo que tenemos que hacer
[Música]
y sin capacitación
nos aseguramos de todos
ahora formalmente el condición
[Música]
en tanto nosotros
en su corazón
mis padres y yo quedamos en medio de los
escombros
bueno el conocimiento
webber lo que agranda
[Música]
lo primero que vi fue a los años 40
uno de ellos
d
otra persona
toda experiencia
para seguir en este mundo
otra persona quería ayuda
desesperadamente
uno de nosotros están listos para morir
los cinco teníamos planes existentes
[Música]
no si no tenemos largas
no sé cuándo tienes 3
en un momento muy breve
la más significativa e incurable
para que pueda pasar
porque dice
no sabes de lo que está mal
muy bien
no hay tiempo para gente
qué pasa
[Música]
ah
el desconocido
nunca jamás
y dependió completamente de personas
que yo lo conocía
los policías que arriesgan su vida en
tradiciones
los paramédicos con unos increíbles
los doctores
muestran a las enfermeras en una
vocación
[Música]
de todo
todos ellos
pero lo mejor de sí para que lo completo
extraño pudiera ser
fueron muchas
[Música]
con mucha gente que puede estar
necesitando
o
para saberlo
dedicada al pensamiento desde los
entrenamientos
nunca
[Aplausos]
mi estado socioeconómico
[Música]
simplemente viernes anual en necesidad
yo necesitaba de ellos
quince días después desciende a
despertar
es enorme
hasta ese momento mi familia
d
y esta vez
así no pasa nada
estaba
y yo sabía que en ese edificio
siniestrado personas que también querían
después
entonces
con el proceso de reconstrucción así
como la ciudad necesita
tuve que ver qué escribir
lo que había perdido
la vida
no tenía nada
[Música]
había perdido mi trabajo
tenemos
lo que no me parece fueron sentimientos
mis ganas y fuerzas de aprendizajes mi
experiencia inteligente
y eso
[Aplausos]
principalmente en una
cómo
confía en las personas yo sé que en este
momento somos testigos de situaciones
tristes complejas violentas
[Música]
hay muchas personas
y lo hace en el presente
sí
pero también por acción
su corrupción de una edición más
construida
puede licenciar donde la empresa
conocía el lado oscuro del senado
pero también así
en el lado solidario
el plazo
la otra cosa
sarkozy
como se los dije al principio mi forma
de ver altera completamente llena de
euros
es una sede
con los
no no no
ella es positivo en la cocina
con las cosas claras
y
me quito - muchas cosas
pero lo que tengo que es américa mi
familia
es decir
yo lo que nosotros como sociedad
los invito a confiar en la próxima que
está con ustedes
[Música]
y
los invito a que confiamos en la bondad
en la solidaridad de las personas
de verdad
[Aplausos]
quiero
las cosas buenas
[Música]
las cosas malas sólo a veces pasando
[Aplausos]